it's an argument that former speaker
McCarthy made with great Passion the
problem is it's not true in every single
war that America has
fought we have never asked for land
afterwards except for enough to bury the
Americans who gave the ultimate
sacrifice for that freedom we went in
for we fought our first war from land
when we took this land from the Brits
then we fought subsequent Wars for land
we fought Wars for land against the
Indians we I think totally justifiable
Wars we fought a war against Spain and
then we got a lot of land from Spain as
a result of that we fought War we fought
a lot of Wars for land if this is really
what conservatives believe about our
history then we're sunk because it means
not only does the left misunderstand
history but the right does as well